[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the former president of the ACLU a board
member for fire epic and the heterodox
Academy a professor at New York law
school and author of the new book hate
why we should resist it with free speech
not censorship nadine strossen welcome
to the Rubin report to be here Dave so I
have to tell you when I was reading
through your bio and looking at all the
boards you've sat on and head of ACLU
and all that I don't know that anyone
has ever been more of sort of a perfect
prime guest to sit in that chair and my
prior book defending pornography
attention we can get into that too but
really your your life's work is sort of
exactly why I do this show and I know
I'm setting you up now with a very you
know high bar here but but this is what
it's all about
well thank you so much and thank you for
your ardent defense of Liberty that that
is the most important value for me and
when people ask me what my politics are
I usually say I care more about my civil
libertarian beliefs than I care about
partisan political beliefs and one of
the things that's true for the ACLU as
well as for me as an individual is not
taking per se across-the-board positions
on any candidate official party or group
but judging on an issue-by-issue basis
and issuing criticism or or praise on an
issue-by-issue basis and there's not a
single party or candidate or official
that hasn't earned some praise and some
criticism on some important civil
liberties issues so looking at the glass
half full an activists I always do that
there's nobody with whom I don't share
some really strong convictions which is
very nice now it's also true that
there's nobody with whom I don't have
some strong disagreements but I'm used
to therefore having a positive
relationship across ideological divides
and and the absence of that or the
fading of that in today's climate is
very bothersome yeah all right what a
great
place to start this conversation then so
as you've seen that PHA that fade in
society do you have a couple markers or
moments where you started to really see
it or has it just been a slow slide into
wherever it seems that we're at at the
moment that's a really good question
Dave and I'm sure some sociologists have
probably analyzed it more exactly my
impression is at least on issues let's
stay with issues of free speech my
strong impression is that there started
to be a real breaking point in around
2015 I think that's when we had the
Ferguson riots and demonstrations and
protests around the country and I am
completely sympathetic to that cause
believe me abuses in the criminal
justice system have been on my radar
screen and the ACL u--'s forever way
back in the dark ages or some would say
the great ages of the eye I meant only
in the sense of old it wasn't a
stigmatizing reference but the Reagan
administration I used to debate his
attorney general ed Meese on
propositions such as is the criminal
justice system racially discriminatory
me so the fan I was taking the yes
profession so the fact that we have this
outpouring in support of social justice
and racial justice and immigrants rights
and anti-sexual violence all of that is
wonderful but starting several years ago
it started to seem more and more that
advocates of these causes began to see
free speech as their enemy rather than
what I know it to be which is their
time-tested essential ally so there was
this pitting of Liberty against equality
of civil rights against civil liberties
and as I say that I realized that it was
the second time that had had
and in my adult lifetime the first time
that that happened very strongly was in
the late 1980s early 1990s which was the
first time that hate speech codes were
proposed on college campuses the first
time we started seeing criticism of what
was called political correctness and
then two especially law professors were
arguing very strongly that you have to
choose you can't have both liberty and
equality and that's an anthem to my own
beliefs and experience yeah and that's
kind of where we're at right now that
seems to be where this argument has
boiled down to so before we unpack all
of that stuff how did you get involved
in this what was it about your education
or your upbringing or whatever else that
made you care about free speech civil
liberties everything else that you just
mentioned it as far back as I can
remember I have been in favor of
individual liberty and resisting anybody
who tried to encroach on my liberty or
that of anybody else's so long before I
had the terminology I resisted my
parents authoritarianism my
schoolteachers authoritarianism I was
kind of a contrarian I would always like
to see a different perspective and I
remember being very puzzled as a fairly
young student maybe I was about 10 or 11
years old and a teacher said to me Oh
Nadine why do you always have to defend
the underdog
she said it as a criticism and to me it
was well they're the ones that need the
defense
I have also always valued freedom of
speech for ideas that I disagree with so
I remember I was in college from 1968 to
1972 very involved in the movement
against the Vietnam or movements for
reproductive freedom that was before the
Supreme Court had decided roe v wade
again the reeling dark ages but I also
always defended freedom for people who
disagreed with me so I would have law
big arguments with members of SDS who
those students for Democratics
by a very radical organization that
wanted to shout down certain speakers
that were in favor of the Vietnam War
administration officials and so forth
and while I disagreed with the points of
view of those speakers I didn't believe
it that they should that we should be
denying them a podium so as far back as
I remember I've been I cared much more
about freedom in part because I do see
that as the essential means to advance
whatever other cause is dear to you it's
hard to defend the people that you don't
like isn't it it seems to me that that's
the one we're forgetting these days like
everyone screams about free speech all
the time
the second someone says I met alike then
they kind of get quiet real quick well
so I was shortly after I graduated from
law school the ACLU and I was not
involved at the national level at all at
that point but the ACLU got involved in
the infamous or famous Skokie case and
that was like a real litmus test I
assume most viewers know what that is
but for those who might not know in 1977
the ACLU came to the defense of the free
speech rights of a group of neo-nazis
who wanted to demonstrate in Skokie
Illinois suburb of Chicago that had a
large Jewish population and a large
population of Holocaust survivors and
many members of the ACLU
even this stalwart free speech
organization lost we lost about 15% of
our members who said we really defend
free speech but this is the one
exception we want to make for this
absolutely abhorrent speech now my
father is a Holocaust survivor I have to
say was sadly he died but it wasn't even
an issue for me I have to tell you Dave
and it's coming back to your question
because you said something about how
does it feel to defend people that you
disagree with and to me I'm
never defending them I'm never defending
their ideas I'm never defending what do
they say I am defending the principle
that government should not have power to
silence speech just because the majority
of the public even the vast majority of
the public loathes despises the idea
that the speech is conveying yeah so
that's incredible obviously I know the
Skokie case well and I'm sure many much
of my audience is I didn't realize 15
percent did you say 15 percent of the
membership ACLU members that's a massive
so and and you know it so the ACLU
really put its money where its mouth is
it was a tremendous financial hit and
there was a lot of negative press now in
fairness fairly soon after that the ACLU
began to recoup members maybe not
necessarily the same people in fact
other people who wrote in and said we
see that you really are neutrally
defending civil liberties even for
people that are anti civil liberties
themselves now that said I have to tell
you almost every time I give a speech
anywhere people will come up to me and
say I was an ACLU member but I quit over
Skokie Rea Nayar who was the executive
director at the time and interestingly
enough himself a Holocaust survivor he
was born in Berlin his extended family
was completely exterminated by the Nazis
he and his immediate family escaped and
and he wrote a wonderful book about it
afterwards called defending my enemy
which I quote in my book and we could
talk about how that might seem
paradoxical but it's it's really not but
anyway in this context I brought him up
because he said to me Nadine if every
person who said they left the ACLU over
Skokie really had been a member we would
have been
agent in the world right they were
talking a big game but there you go
but you okay if I can just follow up on
that it's it's not just an abstract
principle because you can really see how
the principle has concrete ramifications
for exactly the opposite idea
so in our briefs in the Skokie case we
pointed out that the arguments that were
being made to justify suppressing the
Nazis namely that their ideas were
offensive and insulting and threatening
and seen as dangerous to the Jews of the
Holocaust survivors in Skokie that was
exactly the same set of arguments that
was made not that much earlier in 1968
when Martin Luther King was trying to
demonstrate in Cicero Illinois the very
same state but with a very different
population that saw his ideas as
threatening and dangerous and subversive
offensive and insulting right and this
is where this weird subjective nature of
this comes in which is why you've said
several times now you're defending the
principle not the person and that that
of course is the is the key to this
whole thing but we've been pushed into
this place these days where it seems
like there's a large set of people or
certainly a set of very loud people who
think that speech is violent
it ain't violence well I suppose speech
could advocate violence it could incite
violence it could threaten violence so
do you say do you agree with where we
have the laws now in terms of you can't
directly incite and that sort of thing
do you think all those laws are just and
appropriate absolutely and I have to say
even though I've been teaching
constitutional law in the First
Amendment for decades the process of
writing this book and thinking about it
an even more focused fashion really
increased my respect for US law and I
really think that for many people if
they would just understand what the law
actually provides they would be much
more supportive of freedom of speech
because it is much more nuanced and much
more common sensical than is often
misdescribed when people say either Oh
hate speech is not free speech
we heard that a lot including when you
were at the University of New Hampshire
that a lot right and then conversely
people will say Oh hate speech is
protected and neither generalization is
correct yes I this fact that speech has
a hateful or hated message idea or
content can never be a justification for
censoring it but if in a particular
context a hateful message along with any
other message directly causes certain
serious specific imminent harm and
there's no way to avert that harm other
than punishing the speech then the
speech can and should be punished and
common examples that satisfy that
standard are intentional incitement of
imminent violence a genuine threat that
instills fear that you're going to be
subject to violence another example is a
hate crime and that is it's it's it's a
little bit different in the sense that a
and I'm going so much into Mike we're
gonna go we're going into the weeds but
that's good okay so if I can say there's
no term hate speech and that was a point
that you made in your university of new
happy when I said that and it's a fact
that is subscribed to by every single
Supreme Court justice across the
ideological spectrum you know from
Ginsburg and Sotomayor on the left to
Alito and Gorsuch and Scalia on the
right and I think that's a very very
important point that for all of their
ideological differences on so many
issues that so many justices every
justice in modern history has subscribed
to this principle and I wish that people
across the ideological spectrum in other
you know branches of government in the
general public would share that
unanimity because no matter who you are
no matter what you believe you really
have a stake in denying the government
and the majority of people that wield
power taking away
from you the choice about which views
you will express or listen to or refute
so in that University of New Hampshire
speech that I know you watched when when
I was saying there you know hate speech
is not real obviously I was making the
distinction between the direct call to
violence which I actually said unless
it's a direct call to violence but hate
speech in and of itself is is nothing
it's not a it's not a thing you can say
mean things I would prefer you don't we
wish we could all be nice to each other
and say lovely things that use pronouns
the way people wanted and all of those
things but you can have a government
doing it is there anything else that I
should have added in that that perhaps
could have gotten those young people to
listen I think that they were disposed
not to listen but fir'd there were
obviously some open-minded people in the
audience and those are the ones that
you're I mean the hecklers I think were
we're not they didn't seem genuinely
interested in hearing you out but many
other people there did and the other
point that that I would make
strategically Dave and I already did it
and pointing out the Martin Luther King
counterpart to the Nazis is I always
tried to give an example we're an idea
that you happen to support that the
person I'm talking to really supports
would be threatened if we gave that
power to the government so for that that
audience where you have people chanting
black lives matter I would have pointed
out how many government officials now
are saying black lives matter advocacy
should be treated as hate speech that
even saying that black lives matter
should be treated as a hate group the
Southern Poverty Law Center which
monitors hate groups has been lobbied to
treat black lives matter as such and so
then you have to say to people you have
to understand that it's not your values
that are going to be implemented by the
enforcing officials across the country
and if we have this loose nebulous
concept I mean hate is an emotion that's
inherently subjective what one person
considers hateful somebody else
cherishes yeah so you mentioned this
other poverty
Center I don't want to get you in any
hot water here but they to me strike me
as an organization that is completely
completely with almost no reservation
can I say this gone off the rails they
have you know between now they just just
in this last week they they lost this
lawsuit imagine Waze is getting a three
point three million dollar settlement
but they had ayaan Hirsi Ali and
Brigitte Gabriel and several other
people who I've had on the show who I
think are wonderful people on their hate
list they just put up a an article about
the evils of Prager University and and
called me out by name what am I to make
of the shifting of traditionally
organizations that were doing good work
into becoming what I would say are
really far left advocacy groups instead
of maybe the original mission statement
do you think that's not knowledgeable
enough about the instances that you cite
saw back to something I said at the
beginning which is I don't endorse or
criticize any organization across the
board I look at it issue by issue and I
think the Southern Poverty Law Center
has done a lot of good work on issues
that that I care about including freedom
of speech on campus and they definitely
oppose censorship including of hate
speech I testified with a leader of the
SPLC before Congress last year and
completely opposed to censorship
completely supporting counter speech and
in fact the SPLC put out a wonderful
guide for college students at the
beginning of the last academic year
urging them when white supremacist
recruiters are coming to campus not to
engage in disruption not to try to
censor them or to shout them down but to
ignore them
and I thought that was right not only in
principle but also as a matter of
strategy because you're just playing
into their tactics now does that mean
that every single thing they've done is
is is praiseworthy I doubt it I I think
even the ACLU is not above criticism
yeah so I know when when they sent over
some notes
about what what we potentially could
talk about your book and everything else
so because you did watch that University
of New Hampshire thing there's a moment
where a girl that was challenged me kept
implying that it was free speech sort of
that led to the Holocaust that it was
this that we they allowed in citement
and that that's what's led to it now my
basic argument was the more speech there
is the more we can allow sunlight to
disinfect bad ideas but I think perhaps
I could have been a little more forceful
there if you were standing next to me
when we were doing this what would you
have been saying in my ear to that
argument that if we just keep letting
people say all these awful things that
it can lead to awful things and awful
things obviously have happened
throughout the course of human I have a
lot of answers but let me start with the
one that is most specific to the
Holocaust and again I have a personal
stake and I know you also lost relatives
in the Holocaust for me my father
fortunately survived but he was in a
concentration camp and suffered
grievously doing forced labor and in
fact was scheduled to be sterilized and
then was liberated by the US military
one day before so you know I almost had
my life exterminated before it began I
have no love loss from of the Nazis in
fact there was there were hate speech
laws in the Vimal republic during in
which is in Germany where Hitler rose to
power and the hate speech laws were very
similar to the ones that exist in
Germany and other countries today they
were very strictly enforced Nazis were
prosecuted and convicted repeatedly and
guess what they loved it
it was a huge propaganda opportunity for
them they gained attention and support
that they otherwise never would have had
just like the neo-nazis in Skokie all
those years later nobody would have
heard of them if we had just allowed
them to have their miserable little
March for the 20 minutes to 30 minutes
think we're seeking to march instead it
becomes two years worth of worldwide
attention now the problem in
in pre Nazi Germany was that there was
no protection against violence that the
Nazis were engaging in so their
political opponents as well as Jews and
others were subject literally to
physical assault and even murder without
any sufficient protection or punishment
so the other point I would make is that
those of us who are minorities and Jews
are a tiny minority in this country and
around the world especially depend on
freedom of speech because by definition
we're never going to have majority power
so all we have to depend on to limit the
majority from trampling on our rights is
freedom of speech to protest the First
Amendment right of association to the
right to petition the government for
redress of grievances Jonathan Roush a
great gay rights advocate who my quota
my luck makes the same point about you
know as a member of sexual orientation
minority all minorities especially
depend on free speech I quote all a lot
of civil rights leaders in my book
Martin Luther King the n-double-a-cp
throughout the civil rights movement
were completely opposed to censorship
including hate speech laws in part
because their speech was viewed as hated
and even hateful and certainly dangerous
how concerned are you about
self-censorship not not the government
doing it but what I see more is the sort
of the low-level war right now which is
just the emails that I get every day
about people afraid to speak up at work
people afraid to speak up at college
people literally afraid to speak up in
their own homes because they've been so
crushed by political correctness they
don't want to start fights with loved
ones it's it's a serious problem and I
have to say it's a difficult problem
because to some extent the point of
counter speech which I advocated by the
way that's a legalistic way of saying
anything you disagree with you just rate
rather
trying to squelch it stopping that
expression from coming out you respond
to it you debate it you try to persuade
you cajole
so that's countering an idea you dislike
with your own speech to some extent the
goal of counter speech is to chill
certain speech and certain ideas right
you want to dissuade somebody from
adhering to white supremacist views you
don't see it as bad if they self censor
right but when does that persuasion
cross the line into bullying or
harassment I think that's a very
important and difficult issue which was
discussed very extensively in the famous
John Stuart Mill essay on Liberty many
people who haven't recently read it
wouldn't be surprised as I was because I
hadn't read it for a few years I keep a
copy of it with me on my travels that
somebody reminded me that his main focus
there was not on direct government
coercion but rather on the social
pressure that is exerted by colleagues
peers civil society and in this country
on the one hand I'm very glad that there
is such a robust civil society
condemnation of racist tweets by
Roseanne Barr to cite a fairly recent
example on the other hand I'm afraid of
the mob ruthlessly punishing somebody
who may have just said something that's
insensitive and and and I'm concerned
about that David not only because I
don't want to you know the mob is no
more appealing as a force that drives
certain ideas out of existence than the
government yes but I'm also concerned
from the point of view of educating and
persuading
and you know I've met people that have
been not only members but leaders of
hate groups who have come to see that
they were wrong who have come to realize
that all of us are equal and entitled to
equal dignity and equal rights and
they've repudiated their formerly
discriminatory ideas and they didn't
come to that change by being denounced
as racists much less as would happen in
Europe by being imprisoned as as racists
so if our goal truly is to gain more
support on the part of more people for
the ideals of liberty and justice and
human rights and equality and dignity
for all I think we don't do it by by
shouting them down so it's a strategic
question as well as a principled
question yeah is that just one of those
things where it's like in the moment
that we live in we often don't live up
to our ideals in the best way possible
because you reference being a
constitutional law professor and I've
got the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution framed right in that
room right over there and it's like
these guys that were writing these
incredible documents that have given
more freedom to more people than in the
history of the world while some of them
were slave owners and and plenty of
other things and probably women Iser x'
and whatever and it's like but yet they
were writing the things that freed us
which is an incredible that's just a
little something about being human nice
and I think it ties back to to some of
our earlier conversation that so much of
what passes as debate such as your
hecklers at the University of New
Hampshire it's not genuinely engaged in
really trying to relate to you as a
full-fledged human being with whom they
might I have absolutely no doubt based
on my experience that there are no two
people in the world who won't have at
least some strong common concern some
idea that their passion that they both
deeply care about and are committed to
and
and some that they deeply disagree about
and I think it's not it's really
important not to paper over the
disagreements I think we should discuss
them and hash them out but I think we
can do that more constructively and
effectively if we also find what we have
in common and and relate to each other
in in a holistic way all right so there
does seem to me to be a rebirth of a
defense of free speech starting again on
the left possibly I see a little
southern happening I said Jonathan Haidt
at heterodox and some of the other
organizations you're involved in and
fire there is this group of people kind
of making a comeback on the Left I'm not
so sure it can hold I hope it can hold
but what do you make of how this sort of
bounces back where sometimes free speech
is something that the Left holds more
dear sometimes it's something the right
holds more dear and it kind of switches
as the decades
well my perspective and I'm not far be
it for me to pull out the age card but I
think I said a few more decades than you
have and and then it's been a constant
that was very well summed up by Nat
Hentoff whom you would have loved I
don't know if you ever crossed paths
with him but he was a great free speech
stalwart and he wrote a book whose title
really says it all freedom of speech for
me but not for the how the left and
right relentlessly censor each other and
he wrote that decades ago but it's
always been true that most people being
human believe in free speech in general
but those ideas that they hate or
despise or think are dangerous should be
the exception let's go back to Skokie
where ACLU members even 15% of these
die-hard stalwart ACLU members I'm not
surprised that the one exception they
want to make is for speech that's
denigrating civil liberties and human
rights but I had a friend who was the
executive director of the National
Coalition against censorship and she put
it so well she said Nadine everyone has
his or her Skokie so at particular times
that I can tell you for every year I can
tell
you this was the one exception or maybe
more than one exception that liberals
wanted to make and this is the one that
conservatives wanted to make and I would
say in general you know like let's amend
the Constitution so that it is a crime
to burn the American flag that has been
supported by many if not most
conservatives and by a lot of liberals
as well that and there's not been I
think that is the single most hated
expression in my lifetime because no
other expression has led to a
constitutional amendment coming within a
hair's breadth of being ratified more
than two-thirds of the Senate I'm sorry
if the House approved it it came within
one one vote short of two-thirds of the
Senate and more than three-fourths of
the states so all along when was that
maybe that was mid 90s but yeah
something around there wow that's
incredible actually if you think about
it yeah where do you think Trump kind of
fits into the general discussion because
I say look it seems to me that there is
obviously some sort of authoritarian
bent to him that being said we're not
being people are as far as I know people
are being jailed because of free speech
at the moment do you think our
institutions let's say that his worst
critics his were right about whatever
they think about him do you think our
institutions at this point are strong
enough to ward off that kind of threat
and we don't even have to make about
Trump specifically but if there was
truly like a real authoritarian in
office do you think that the the way our
balance of powers and our separation of
powers works and again I would have to
say you know Trump has certainly done a
lot of saber rattling on free speech
issues and you know said that flag
burners should be deported but let us
not forget that Barack Obama was
responsible for the most stringent
enforcement of the Espionage Act and you
know pressing criminal charges against
more whistleblowers than all pre or
prior administrations added together so
again a pox on on both your houses so
far
courts have been a wonderful bulwark the
flag-burning example is a really good
one it was a to Supreme Court decisions
joined by both conservatives and
liberals on the court that struck down
under the First Amendment laws that
criminalized desecrating the american
flag well the Supreme Court doesn't have
quite the last word a constitutional
amendment could overturn it but I have
great confidence that this Court would
continue to uphold what has been called
the bedrock principle of freedom of
speech and that is viewpoint neutrality
I summarized it earlier that the mere
fact that the viewpoint is hated whether
it be flag burning or whether it be
racist speech that is never a
justification for censorship again they
unanimously endorsed that last summer in
a hate speech case yeah let's slightly
shift for a second so when you were the
head of the ACLU what are the political
pressures that you're under that maybe
the average person wouldn't know from
that from the headlines like involvement
with pop you know politicians with
lobbyists et cetera et cetera so the
ACLU was is and I was personally
involved in in lobbying and testifying I
still do testify before Congress
occasionally and I would say to me it
was a very privileged position because
we did not have to be directly concerned
about partisan political pressures we
could simply make alliances and work
with anybody that we thought could
support an issue that advanced our cause
even if we disagreed with them on other
issues and I remember to me it was a
great source of pleasure I remember on
one piece of legislation testifying
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
and the chair was Orrin Hatch and that
ranking minority member was Ted Kennedy
and they were both supporting this same
Pro civil liberties positions
I was testifying together with the head
of the National Association of
Evangelicals and the head of the Mormon
Church and despite all of the
differences on so many other issues the
fact that we could make common concern
that was on principles of religious
liberty and freedom of thought and
freedom of belief that's what I feel is
deteriorating a little bit so last year
I testified a couple of times on campus
free speech issues and the
bipartisanship had really worn down even
though the theme was freedom of speech
on campus and even though the chair of
the committee who was Lamar Alexander
Republican and patty Murray the ranking
member Democrat they were both really
solid and great on the issue but the
other members of the committee just used
it as opportunities to trot out their
own ideas of which free speech was bad
and should be suppressed so some of the
Republicans were saying taking a knee by
athletes should be punished and some of
the Democrats were really saying Trump
is violating free speech and there was
too much political grandstanding all
right and that's why far as critical as
I am for the left I don't want free
speech to become I don't want it to be a
political issue in the first place I
don't want it to be that the right which
at the moment I see more tolerance
related to diversity of ideas I don't
want that to be the home I want there to
be a balance otherwise we're just gonna
end up in that right well it may be a
little bit skeptical but I think that
people tend to be result oriented and
that on the right there may be much more
support for freedom of speech on campus
because they see that its views on the
right that are being squelch now in
fairness I'll give you a counter example
many years ago during this first surge
of political correctness on campus Mitch
McConnell let me play me and let me put
it backwards
it was Henry Hyde I'm sorry a
conservative Catholic from Illinois who
was completely on the opposite side of
the ACLU on abortion and
gay rights he really was so strong on
campus free speech that he sponsored a
bill that would have required all
private universities to respect the same
free speech rights that public
universities are required to observe
under the Constitution many people don't
know this but the Constitution only
applies to government including state
universities but not private university
how do you guys feel about well we've
totally supported the ledges that would
be a difference between libertarians and
civil libertarians my libertarian
friends would say you know keep the
government out of it let the private
institutions decide and there were
exemptions for religious institutions
but basically I think that's where I
would fall on this so sell me sell me
your way it's a very interesting debate
and I can understand but the person you
know I've had this discussion with my
dear friends at the Cato Institute for
many many years now what's the
difference between a classical liberal
or libertarian and civil libertarian I
think that we are less opposed to
government regulation when it is in the
service of regulating very powerful
private sector actors that for all
practical purposes the way we were
talking about civil society earlier can
exercise coercive power that stifles
people's liberty so so what if you you
know if you if if we did not have the
1964 Civil Rights Act
then even the most powerful large
landlord employer corporation private
university or etc would be able to
discriminate on the basis of race or
gender under federal law they still can
on the basis of sexual orientation I
would view that as something that could
and should be remedied through passing a
statute making that illegal hmm Richard
Enda well I think well first off I agree
with you your basic premise here is that
the idea level it's a great place for a
rich conversation yeah the idea that the
government would be coming in and
telling private schools even though I
understand what you're saying that they
would have
adhere to these codes even if I think
you being the First Amendment right yeah
I don't necessarily think a private
school should have to do that I just
think that ultimately the market would
just you'd either decide you want to go
there or don't want to go there this one
this one's definitely tough it's an
interesting one and I definitely can see
the other side and I certainly would
insist on some exemptions certainly for
religious schools I think military
schools were also exempted but then I
want to give you another example of a
Republican that I worked with Mitch
McConnell works very closely with the
ACLU in opposing many people are going
to be surprised to hear this the
mccain-feingold
law a campaign so called campaign
finance like a lifetime ago ACLU very
you know we are the ones who argued
Buckley versus Valeo and arguing that
the ability to spend money in order to
promote a message is protected free
speech and it should be protected even
when the speech is engaged in by people
who are organized into a group and
including if they're organized in the
form of a corporation or a union or
not-for-profit corporation so some
liberals are really distressed by that
position and I think it's absolutely the
correct one anyway what do you say to
those those liberals or the lefties who
do get more upset about that in general
that you're just going to allow
corporations to endlessly pour money in
the system and manipulate the system and
that's it well yeah and again what is
the lesser of two evils would I rather
have the government telling corporations
such as the ACLU and Planned Parenthood
and the Sierra Club you name your
favorite left-wing so-called cause and
it is organized in corporate form and
the ACLU under that law was it would
have been a crime to go on the airwaves
and by name call on people who are
running for federal office and say you
know repeal the Patriot Act because
arguing for issues over the bra
caste airwaves was a crime under that
law and spending your own money to
advance your own issue-oriented message
so I think people are shocked when they
hear what the law actually did and are
persuaded that in at least some
applications that went too far
well McConnell became such a supporter
of free speech as a result of working on
this issue that he actually changed his
position on the flag burning amendment
he had been a big proponent of it and as
having seen how important freedom of
speech was including for what two
liberals is a very controversial form of
speech namely spending money in the
political process he said well you know
I've got to stick to principles here and
we should not amend the Constitution to
outlaw another controversial expression
so I thought that was a really wonderful
idea of not just being result oriented
toward your own ideological concerns but
seeing their overarching principle and
following it it's almost like if you
actually have the debate you might
change people's mind and be surprised to
your allies suddenly are is there any
country that is protecting these rights
better than we are
now for as screwy as our system may be
no well let me make on sexual expression
the United States is much more
repressive than European some many
European countries but like in what
regard you mean with yeah so we still
have I mean not only sexual expression
but four-letter words I mean thank
goodness we're not broadcasting because
I still get bleeped even when I say
whatever you want all seven of them okay
well and and when one of them appears
and I'm not even sure if this was one of
these seven but [ __ ] the draft was
upheld as of in a very important free
speech case it by the United States
Supreme Court and this is a case that
has ramifications for hate speech as
well but I
cannot describe the facts of that case
on radio or TV and they another country
and we still have anti obscenity law I
mean let's not forget that the brouhaha
about the the wardrobe malfunction at
Super Bowl I mean it's so we're much
more puritanical but when it comes to
political expression there's no country
that gives as much protection as we do
including for hateful racist speech and
misogynistic speech including for
defamation
you know defamatory falsehoods about
public officials and public figures and
that's why there are so many libel
lawsuits that are brought in the UK
against what would be clearly protected
speech in this country yeah but you do
believe in our libel laws here yes I you
know I I'm sure I would want to trim
them back a little bit but on the whole
we're quite protective so if it's a
matter of public concern or public
official or public figure you get quite
a bit of leeway you can't be held
culpable unless you have acted
intentionally or recklessly and I think
that's correct and one of the they're
pretty specific yeah one of the things
that that Trump wanted to do as he said
was to reform the libel laws to make it
easier for a public official to to
collect damages and you know a lot of
people say oh come on Nadine Britain and
Germany and France and Canada and
Australia you know it's not as if they
are two tellurian authoritarian
countries but if you read the examples
in my book of the kinds of speech that
are being punished even with
imprisonment even with criminal fines
and that's the tip of the iceberg
because for every punishment there is
there are countless numbers of of
self-censorship incidents it would
really make your skin crawl give
examples no matter what your ideology is
you should find something in there that
you would say oh my goodness I can't
believe it so you know France a couple
of years ago criminally
convicted the head of a gay rights
organization for calling the head of an
anti gay rights organization a homophobe
me that was considered to be hate speech
now fortunately she wasn't sentenced to
prison but she was subject to a very
stiff fine $3,500 and and and then you
think what are the ripple effects of
that yeah
have you guys tracked this case with the
comedian in the UK who had the dog
oh yeah salute yes I mean again like
it's like all right first up he was
making a joke there's no there's no
exception for humor or satire when the
new online hate speech laws went into
effect in Germany on January 1st the
first person convicted or charged under
it was one of the leaders of a
right-wing party not surprisingly but
the very and then maybe the first two
that were charged were from that party
but the very next one was a satirical
magazine that was making fun of their
statements mocking them ridiculing and
and and and these laws by being so
subjective can't make the fine
distinctions between humorous satire and
straightforward advocacy yeah so my
audience knows I'm not big on the the
globalist ideas here or even the UN I
think it's mostly a forest at this point
but do we need some sort of internet
bill of rights I mean this is a new
phrase that we're that seems to be
popping up over the last year or so that
will uniformly protect people in other
country from via for their ability to
say things that are uncomfortable online
and be able to tweet things that you
know you can't say in Germany but you
can't say in the United States I I think
we have to do that on a
country-by-country basis and I am
pleased that there are advocates in
other countries that really strongly
support freedom of speech including for
hate speech I keep putting that in their
quotes because it as I say to that
person a nude at the University of New
Hampshire no there really is no such
thing and by the way there a lot of what
they said to you some people would
consider to be hate speech too so that's
another
argument that you could have made my one
regret is at one point when she said to
me I said something about losing
Holocaust family members from ha goes on
both sides and then later she said
they're rolling in their graves over
what I'm saying I mean try to think like
if this if we're really if we're really
gauging the offense meter yeah I assure
you there was nothing that I said in
those two hours that was more wildly
offensive than that but do I want her
jailed because of that I mean of course
not so I really was heartened at how
much support there is for the American
approach we're often attacked as being
American Exceptionalist and it wouldn't
bother me if we were the only ones in
the in the world that were defending our
free speech principles as long as that
is the right thing to do but it's
interesting that other people having
seen despite the good intentions of
sensorial laws elsewhere how they are
leading to results that no thinking
person should accept and handing over to
these online so here we get to this
question again I'll put it this way Dave
what's the lesser of two evils to allow
these private agglomerations of power
internet companies decide pick and
choose whose speech is allowed and who's
not and enforcing their own concepts of
hate speech or pornography or
permissible or impermissible nudity to
pick just a few examples that they
enforce would I rather have them have
that enormous power or would I rather
have the government say no we're gonna
check your power to restrict other
people's free speech rights and to me
that's a very difficult yes so that's it
okay so that's exactly where we were
before with the universities and that's
where I would say ultimately right now
are four I don't know how many internet
companies we have let's say comcast
spectrum they're all one the net
neutrality issue and I'm thinking of the
social media that you know the
Facebook's and the Twitter's having
these armies of enforcers saying that's
hate speech we're going to take it down
right so I guess what I would say is
that if there were certain internet
companies that were saying alright well
we're not going to allow pornography on
our pipes or we're not going to allow
this type of speech' that that was each
I would still prefer that you as the
consumer would have more choice exactly
then then the government saying we have
to enforce all these things okay totally
but because of the inter because of the
internet now I know this is a unique
situation related to free speech that's
a little I mean my ideal world I'm
completely with you the question is and
I'm not an economist my husband is and
he tells me that it's very complicated
have some of them amassed so much power
that word that we should use antitrust
type tools to prevent them for that that
they are denying us choice through their
market power right so this is it there's
a great conversation to be had there
this is where my friends at Prager
University who I agree with on all sorts
of stuff they were suing Google YouTube
over restrictions to their videos which
I wasn't for because I don't want the
antitrust stuff to because to me that
that then means you just create a
zillion other problems down the road but
that's a great place for a free speech
person and an economist and probably a
technology guy at all sit down and work
this stuff out without choking each
other there was a to me really
frightening story in The New York Times
a few weeks ago
featuring Facebook's deletion Center
that's what it was actually called this
huge building in Berlin where they had
literally hundreds of people that are
looking at individual posts in deciding
should this be deleted should it not be
deleted and it was you know in the
examples you you realize how inevitably
subjective it is ultimately they took
down when they took down this this
comment that was posted by the
politician she was calling certain
Muslim men rapists and the question was
was she referring to the particular
Muslim immigrants who were in fact
convicted rapists there was a horrible
incident on New Year's Eve a couple of
years ago in which case one would hope
that would be protected speech because
she's describing something factual or
was she perhaps insinuating that all
Muslim men are rapists which would not
would be a generalization that I would
find objectionable but and but it would
be illegal under German law and the
official you know these people it's
their whole job to make these decisions
they couldn't agree between themselves
and so of course if you're not sure
which way it goes and you're facing a
fifty million euro fine if the German
government says it is hate speech
well guess which way yeah yeah what do
you think right now is our biggest
censorship threat what do you think is
coming on the horizon I I'm gonna be
very general because it's been the same
answer I've had throughout my decades of
activism which is lack of public
understanding and awareness of what the
First Amendment is what it does protect
what it does not protect what the
rationales are I truly believe that the
more people understand both what the
principles are and how we have evolved
app toward those principles through
historic experience that people will be
supportive so I'm curious during the
whole NFL kneeling thing I've made a
couple videos about it and obviously we
talked about it on the show but I
basically was saying look this is free
speech working the president said what
he said now I would certainly prefer
that the president not call people sons
of [ __ ] right but he's entitled to
free speech he didn't try to enact the
law to stop them so he spoke the players
could then kneel or not kneel so they
were able to do what they wanted the
owners could then you know find the
players or not so they got to do what
they wanted the fans could say I'm gonna
buy jerseys and attend games or I'm not
gonna so everyone's speech actually
everyone's speech and action was
protected you might have some
consequences for it but to me it was a
great example of the whole thing working
messy but working do you think that's a
fair information solely agree with that
and I'm it's a quite similar analysis
myself to the disappointment of people
who did not realize that the NFL as a
private entity
it's own rights including its own free
speech rights and I thought it was
interesting that some of the owners said
they would allow their players to
express their their protests is in in
that case though is Trump getting it as
close to where it could be an issue for
the ACLU or other similar organizations
as he can without directly calling for a
law because there is some other well I
don't even know what that phrase is but
there's something else happening there
when he's calling he were threatening if
he were threatening to pass a law yeah
and he did that in one other context I
think he threatened that there should be
some FN FCC license should be taken away
from some broadcaster that comes much
closer to line and the principal Dave
you're exactly right he does not give up
his free speech rights by virtue of
being a government official but if he is
speaking in official capacity and
threatening some adverse consequences
that could be seen as an abridgment of
free speech under which would visor
yeah so in the past I think the closest
Supreme Court case we have is where a
government Commission wrote a letter
that threatened that it would take some
action and even though it wasn't
starting a prosecution or it wasn't an
order to cease the expression the court
said you know it was a very functional
practical concept it would a reasonable
person feel deterred in pursuing their
free speech after they hear this
communication and again reasonable
people can disagree about what the
answer to that is but that's the
question
we should put in evaluating whether
Trump has crossed the line or not so one
of the things that I saw when the NFL
released its new standard now for next
season where the players are allowed to
stay in the locker room or not and again
everyone's choice will will or will not
have consequence I saw a lot of people
that were saying well clearly the
government involved you know interfered
behind the scenes now I know there's no
I know you don't suspect you don't have
some sort of an outside knowledge
something like that that's where there
would be a problem though if they were
really
you know behind-the-scenes meetings
where they were saying you're going to
institute this new policy on that but
short of having that information
everything kind of worked yeah there
there's another analogy I can think of
which is where the government has
threatened certain businesses that if
you don't adopt a voluntary restriction
on speech then we're going to pass
legislation so for example the movie
rating system or sound recording rating
systems that we think these labels are
stigmatizing and therefore suppressing
certain expression I think there's a
very strong argument that the only
reason this so-called voluntary system
was put in place in both businesses is
because they knew that if they didn't do
it the government was going to legislate
it but even that the Supreme Court never
held that that was illegal censorship
yeah all right well we can't talk free
speech for an hour and not mention the
cake
we've got to talk about the day cake
tell me your thoughts on the game cake
okay it's AI first of all I think it
involves not only expression which I
would define quite broadly and again let
me talk about the the standard here
reasonable people can disagree how the
standard applies to the facts of the
case so the court has said and I think
this is correct that something comes
some expression comes or arguable
expression comes within the ambit of the
First Amendment if it is intended to and
can reasonably perceived as conveying a
message at least a general message so
that's the question you would ask about
the cake I think there's at least a
plausible argument that the cake is
satisfied that standard in addition to
expression there's the question of
religious liberty right which I defend
very strongly even more strongly than
the supreme court which has a quite
narrow definition now but I think people
should not be coerced generally to do
something that violates their deeply
held religious or conscientious beliefs
that's only one side of the equation
because neither free no speech nor
religious freedom is absolute and in
general the court has said and I think
this is right that government can
restrict those freedoms if it can show
that there is a countervailing interest
of such compelling importance that can
only be advanced by restricting the
expression or the belief and the
countervailing interest is of course the
dignity and equality of in this case gay
people but in past cases it's been
african-americans or women because
people have cited we're in business have
asserted religious justifications for
not serving members of racial minorities
are not treating women equally and but
to be clear that's not what was
happening here because they could have
walked in and bought any cake off the
shelf a black person - Rachel couple
could have walked in and bought any cake
off the shelf this was about the
specific act that was going to be paint
you know painted or whatever they do on
the gate right you know it's interesting
I and there's another
another free speech principle that's
involved here which is that government
may not compel somebody to proclaim a
certain message that they don't believe
in any more than it may stop somebody
from conveying a message that they that
they do believe in so I would say I'm
I'm very I think they're very strong
concerns on both sides so I'm very
sympathetic because let me finish out
the other argument of course if you're
an independent artist that is you know
only taking assignments on commission
whether it be to paint a portrait or a
landscape or to decorate a cake in a
very elaborate way that's one thing but
if you are doing business with the
general public and basically holding
yourself out as what the law would call
a public accommodation we're open to
all-comers then you may not discriminate
certain bases such as race religion and
I think even though you still can as a
matter of federal law under state law in
that state and and and others you cannot
do that on the basis of sexual
orientation and so I think that very
strong countervailing equality principle
I think should should dominate in in
this analysis so you actually weren't
thrilled with this decision there well I
was I was in the sense that there were
so many ways that the court could have
gone wrong so many issues well they said
that it was a very the best thing they
could do was to be very narrow and I
actually if I were writing in the brief
in the case that's what I would do too
because all of these principles are so
important I deeply care about freedom of
expression including the freedom not to
be compelled to affirm a message that
that violates your beliefs whether
they're religious or conscientious
doesn't matter but I also deeply believe
in equality in the public sphere and the
facts were murky so I think you know as
I think what happened in past situations
with race and gender I think you know
once things once the immediate
resistance died down to the 1964 Civil
Rights Act that it sort of worked its
way out in a way that is maximally
respective respectful of all the
competing rights so I think it's very
good to avoid really broad brush
holdings that might have unanticipated
adverse consequences for other factual
situations that's an interesting take
because I saw some people saying well
they're just sort of kicking this down
the road now but basically saying in a
weird way that's the way a functional
society works at times I think you know
the court sets some general goal posts
and then as time goes by the controversy
may die down people may figure out how
they can live their own lives in ways
that they're not going to be bothered by
by the government not being treated
disrespectfully one of the things that I
really liked about the
opinion in that case and it's so
contrasting to what's happening in the
European countries that I discuss in my
book is that the court talked very
strongly about equality and neutrality
in many different sorry in many
different contexts so not only that you
should be treated with equal dignity
regardless of who you are but also
regardless of what you believe so the
fact that the court was respectful both
of the equal dignity of the gay couple
and of the equal dignity of the
religious beliefs and the free speech
rights of the Baker I really liked that
I'm one of the things that bothers me
very much about what is often paraded as
diversity on campus is that it only
looks at one dimension it looks at
demographic diversity in terms of who
you are but not in terms of of what you
believe and in these European countries
that are enforcing hate speech laws you
see them going both ways depending on
who's in power so certain religious
beliefs are being punished and
criminalized as hate speech if they run
against what is a dominant secular
orthodoxy in those societies whereas in
others communities certain criticism of
religion is treated as hate speech and
criminalized when it's the religious
belief that is held by those in dominant
power I think the main takeaway here is
that freedom is messy but we're doing a
pretty decent job of it here well thanks
to those who keep agitating right
eternal vigilance there you go well it's
been a pleasure chatting with you and
for more on Nadine check out her new
book hate why we should resist it with
free speech not censorship and we're
going to link to it right down below
[Music]